hallo und herzlich willkommen zu den
deutschen web video tagen und damit auch
zum deutschen web video preis mein name
ist christoph krachten normalerweise in
der wirklich prominente in der online
talkshow clixoom jetzt freue ich mich
aber dieses außergewöhnliche ereignis
anzukündigen den deutschen web video
preis denn dieser preis hat gefehlt und
sie und ihr könnt mit machen start ist
der achtzehnte januar und bis zum ersten
februar können videos vorgeschlagen
werden auf der webseite webvideo tage.de
es gibt acht kategorien und eine
hochkarätig besetzte jury zum beispiel
mit dem elektrischen reporter mario
sixtus oder simon von mtv games schlagt
also die besten videos sie erkennt vor
damit dieser preis maßstäbe setzt es
liegt also an euch und an ihm
preisverleihung ist dann am 20 februar
in essen im rahmen einer großen gala und
da werden wir zeigen was alles im web
videos steckt bis dahin